aquí tenemos tres problemas de sumas
diferentes lo que quiero que hagas es
aprovechar que puedes pausar este vídeo
para que intentes hacerlas por ti mismo
mientras lo haces no olvides que es lo
que significa realmente llevar
suponiendo que lo vas a intentar yo lo
intentaré lo que quiero decir es que lo
vamos a intentar juntos tenemos que
nueve más seis son 15 así que escribimos
el 5 en el lugar de las unidades y luego
llevamos 1 pero qué fue lo que hicimos
en realidad que representa este 1
como lo pusimos en el lugar de las
decenas una decena representa 10 todo lo
que digo es que 96 es igual a 10 5 una
decena más 5 que son 15 acá en el lugar
de las decenas tenemos 1 + 0 + 9 son 10
escribimos 0 en el lugar de las decenas
y luego llevamos el 11 09 es 10 qué
significa esto esto es una decena más 0
decenas más 9 decenas es igual a 10
decenas 10 decenas es 100 u otra forma
de ver a un 100
es una centena más 0 decenas así que
esto es lo que significa llevar
acá tenemos 17 + 9 que son 17 y tenemos
que recordar que este es el lugar de las
centenas en realidad esto es 100 más 700
más 900 o bien 17 centenas 17 centenas
son 1700 claro mil 705 por el 5 que
teníamos acá y terminamos la primera
tratemos de resolver la segunda
la razón por la que la escribía así es
para no olvidarnos de alinear los
números en los lugares correspondientes
así que la podemos reescribir como 373
más las unidades las ponemos en el lugar
de las unidades y las decenas en el
lugar de las decenas
3 + 8 son 11 el 1 va en el lugar de las
unidades y el 1 va en el lugar de las
decenas 10 más uno es igual a 11
17 son 8 88 son 16 escribir el 16 6 en
el lugar de las decenas y 1 en el lugar
de las centenas porque 16 decenas son
160 así que este 6 es 60 y acá tenemos
un 100
13 son 4 que es lo mismo que 4 centenas
o 400 y obtenemos 461
finalmente 93 son 12 2 unidades más una
decena 12 es lo mismo que 10 más 2
en las decenas tenemos 149 son 14
entonces escribimos el 4 en el lugar de
las decenas y llevamos el 1 pero no
olvidemos que esto en realidad es 10 más
40 más 90 que es 140 lo mismo que 40 más
100 y 11 más dos son cuatro pero éste
está en el lugar de las centenas por lo
que en realidad es
sin más 100 más 200 o bien 400 y
terminamos